every country is going to do what's best
in their interest and it's crazy to me
how we can invade somewhere like Iraq
right and for no real reason right we
had a bunch of propaganda after 9 11
people don't even know that Bin Laden
Saddam Hussein didn't even like each
other let alone were allies but we went
ahead and used that excuse of 9 11 to go
ahead and invade Iraq and then no one
said anything to us but if poon goes
into Ukraine which was a part of the
USSR and their serious
um ramifications for NATO being there to
their National Security we're over here
complaining up in arms it's not our
business we need to focus our problems
at home not necessarily Ukraine and I'm
not saying that since so anyone that it
might be Ukrainian or whatever it may be
but you got to understand that every
country is going to operate in their own
best interest for National Security